Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P, here is our a caller
who calls in regularly, one who he seems to
be taking issue with double blind placebo
controlled trial. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: Hey, there it is.
Speaker 1: One here.
Speaker 2: I want to present the case
against double blind, placebo.
Speaker 1: Controlled.
Speaker 2: And systematically reviewed trials.
So I don't know much about this, but I am. Okay.
Speaker 1: So that would be the first red flag.
I don't know much about this,
but let's listen anyway. My best.
So if they.
Speaker 2: Conduct a trial and.
Only 10% of the subjects in the trial.
Benefit from the treatment.
Whatever. They're going to consider.
The trials are not really be any good for me.
Speaker 1: So that's not necessarily true.
What? When you're. Assessing the success, the
effectiveness, the efficacy of a treatment or
drug. You want to compare the effectiveness to
the best available treatment and also have a
placebo arm. So and it should be double blind. So
what you're looking to do is as follows Imagine
that you have some condition, let's call it, you
know, a Trump syndrome, for lack of a better term.
You've got Trump syndrome and you have a pill
that improves symptoms in 10% of people. Great.
That's the best treatment we have. So you design
a test in which you take some people and you give
them the pill that's already on the market. And
you take some people and you give them a placebo
and you take some people and you give them the new
pill. Now, some would argue you don't even in this
case, you don't even really need the placebo,
because the whole point is to compare to the
approved treatment. But you could you could do
it this way. The people should know who's getting
what. The patient shouldn't know. Am I getting the
approved pill, a new pill, or the placebo? Because
knowledge of what they're getting could affect the
results. The people treating them shouldn't know
what they're getting either, so that that would
not influence the results. And then you compare.
Now, imagine if the approved pill works 10% of
the time and the placebo works 10% of the time,
and the new pill works 40% of the time. That now
becomes significant. So there's no hard and fast
numbers, really, the way one is saying here.
Speaker 2: Efficacy, huh? You know,
pretty bad. You normally want more than that,
right? You want at least greater than 50%.
Well, the reason I think that that's bad logic is,
is as follows. If you want to run the experiment
for every person in the United States. And 10%
of the population benefited. That is about. 134.
And people say that isn't enough.
Speaker 1: Okay. The math is the
math is way off. So there's 330
million people in the U.S. So 10%
would be 3 million, not 134,000. But that's
also pretty pretty irrelevant because.
We're not dealing with most conditions. We're not
dealing with a population base that is the entire
country. So this is very confused here. One, I
would do a rethink on this. There is a reason
that the double blind, placebo controlled trial
is the gold standard. And I would rethink this.
All right. On the bonus show today, we will talk
about the vote from Twitter shareholders on the
Elon Musk Twitter takeover takeover. We will talk
about the founder of Patagonia donating the entire
company to fight climate change. And yes, we will
talk about the latest article, the conviction,
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show. Sign up at join Pacman dot com.